hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Garden of ban ban three
the next chapter in the installment and
we've got some new friends we've got a
kangaroo with some horrible nightmare
demons in her belly
belly well this should be fun I hope
anyway the last one had some flaws I
mean the first one
let's be perfectly honest here but it's
an enjoyable experience and you know I'm
always here to applaud individual
Developers for a parent looking for
their missing child time is a delicate
matter click the clock to advance time
oh
right
so I don't know I don't know exactly
what that means that was in the second
game too it might have been in the first
one I have no idea
but oh hello right oh the sensitivity is
way too that's better well this is nice
hey friend how you doing it's good to
see you
oh Queen bound Celia says jump as much
as you like but never to conclusions the
naughty ones I knew those were demons
finish your homework and be nice if you
don't want to join us
I'm sorry but two
bird
s
[Music]
yes all right I don't know what those
were about
I never understood what the point of any
of that was
the letters and the whatnot but all
right hello I'm back again
you're not to die stupidly hello
those are not eyes holy crap
I don't know how you did it but then
again you survived the giant elevator
crash so I guess I shouldn't be
surprised
also again I apologize for hitting you
over the head
in fact it is for this reason that I
believe we should not meet face to face
uh-huh you see for whatever reason I'm
prone to Violent instincts and I do not
trust myself to not give in to them
again
I have locked myself inside of a
surveillance rule that way I can help
without being a danger to you we are
currently on the lowest floor to remain
active before everything went awry
there are many floors below us but
they've all remained closed and
abandoned for quite some time now
so just make sure not to fall
as for your children I don't know
exactly where they're being kept but I
know someone who does head to the
Aquatic sector that's where he resides
but okay so there's many contradictions
in what you said
um you said that we were on the lowest
floor and then there were floors below
us and I get that they're inaccessible
but it's still it's a little bit of a
contradiction oh I need batteries that's
just what I said
um well that's convenient yeah
I always knew I was an unlucky person
but this is a new standard I leave a
bustling floor for the washroom and when
I return everybody's gone Without a
Trace which would have been peaceful if
it wasn't for the giant bird walking
around I doubt I can keep this quiet
much longer my breaths circuiting have
very heavy what's the bird doing outside
of its containment anyway I thought they
were showing off only the short purple
creature because we were behind on
schedule
this is not how I imagined my end would
be nor I
nor
I found one battery and
another hello
why is this place so big
I get that they're making like an
underground uh kindergarten
is that what it's supposed to be a
kindergarten right
um but at the same time it seems a
little uh
extraordinary anyway I got my thing back
which is very useful and it says
something about a tape being here
I have no tapes to play no okay well
whatever
so you go oh no not there go
oh man
wow
did you get a speed upgrade you seem a
little bit faster than you were before
which I do appreciate it did take you a
little bit to get anywhere
thank you
hi what's in here wow hey I think I saw
this on a nightmare camera
it just hit me that you need that key
card to operate the cable car
shouldn't be too hard to find wine
literally everyone had a copy it's how
you'd get from Station to Station uh-huh
yeah that seemed to have worked out so
well for everybody
um but when you said everyone had a copy
uh it seems like everyone's dead oh
never mind hello
dear Mommy the nice jellyfish is very
strong he carried everyone to here but
miss Mason hates him and I don't know
why I don't know who Miss Mason is so
maybe that hate is Justified
notice two janitors cleaner checks are
required beforehand if she has Oddities
are to be dropped into them
Oddities what what do you mean Oddities
a cleaner has been dispatched
oh my God
[Applause]
huh
huh I
um a little more than a little confused
I have no Oddities to Trump
no I guess I don't oh an oddity
can't believe this all right yeah I get
it okay so I need to pick up the crayons
is that what I'm to understand
why though
why
okay I think I have all the Oddities
Claire was here not anymore
not anymore
okay I think I got him
one at a time
okay I'm out of oddities I think I got
them all so are you gonna be able to
you gonna be able to actually
[Applause]
you're gonna be able to actually clean
anything
do I need to help you with that oh oh
you're just scanning to see if things
are clean you're not cleaning anything
you're just here would weirdly check
that I did my job
thanks
oh it's clean all right
I know Oddities
good dispense a key card hey
hey wait a minute
I thought I already had a key card I get
another one
well this day is just going my way
where do I do a purple
hi
oh bye that's fine that's definitely
fine nothing weird about that
yay oh
okay
ah this is uncomfortable
why is this so huge
oh
this gives me bad vibes
this gives me very bad vibes and what
happened
okay great good
good
I'm in the Progressive sector what does
that even mean
this is a toy factory or is this is this
a school what is this
the hard hat
uh uh-huh
interesting all right so I don't have a
yellow key card
good
oh God where am I going oh God
why does it need to be so huge all right
but I'm in the medical sector I'm
slightly off Target guys
look I don't mean to be
I don't mean to be nitpicky about this
but that seems slightly off Target oh
good case six the devil k6's rebellious
Behavior remained unchanged even after
the introduction of case seven and so
alternative methods were approved by
management to encourage cooperation one
such method was the introduction of a
newly modified gyvanium solution
engineered to lower the functions of
self-thinking in any cases case two of
type 5 which is responsible for one's
brain functions this newly modified guy
venium solution will never be applied
again and all excess materials will be
locked away under heavy sedation the new
solution is was applied to case's system
shortly after k6 appeared to experience
excruciating stomach pain that was so
aching it fell on its knees while
holding its stomach before undergoing
significant physical changes it appeared
the solution was so effective at
limiting self's thinking that k6 fell
victim to the Primitive instincts we are
so badly trying to avoid case is not
ready for how do you know that that's
the conclusion that you come to oh it
worked but it did the opposite of what
we wanted therefore it it was a success
in every way that it failed that that
doesn't bode confidence in your
scientific process
but hey at least I'm in the medical
sector
uh never mind no I'm not
anything in there can I crouch I cannot
all right uh well this was fun but
goodbye hello arboreal aquatic sector
trees and seas yellow glass is breakable
material uh-huh
I see
fascinating all right you go there
uh-huh
and then there
nice
and keep going there and just because
for good measure unless this is not
breakable but it seems like it might be
whoa
whatever hello I'm here now
no you're so
close there you go
I don't know why but I did that
um hello
good orange
that's what we need
two spider land to smile land and two
octopus land
oh man so many choices
hmm
there's a right somebody for everybody
you just need to look
I don't know that
[Music]
oh hi all right play your game
wow
ow
hi oh oh oh oh oh oh
what
what is that supposed to be I
um are you alive
I notice you have a lot of
fleshy textures veins and tentacles
which is super cool
um
yeah I'm just gonna go right under you
wow this is uncomfortable
hello
hi
don't mind me
oh
don't mind me well I can't move
what did I get stuck on hello
Chris
what
hi oh my God
that's your eyeball Maybe
communication kiosk I I don't know about
that man it's oh okay
hello
[Music]
oh
hi how are you my name is
you diligently wait for the moment you
leave this wretched place with your
childhood I I can also tell
not to undermine your efforts but I fear
that moment may never come I cannot let
it happen
and I will gladly show you why but after
I do enjoy
you take my advice
leave this place while you still can
erase it from your memory
move on and forget any of this ever
happened and I promise you
tomorrow will be a better day
whatever you're about to do don't do it
don't do it
oh good am I in your mind now did you um
oh
[Laughter]
what in the hell is happening
what is going on man uh
oh it's the cool kids
hey what's up guys hey how you doing
good to see you I
this is a
weirdly awesome
I don't know why
but it is
hey yeah hi
when I feel that I'm staying true for
off my original course
I had to the room we have family
meditating again instrument
are you coming to this place
and then I am reminded that what I'm
fighting for is worse all of the space
and suffering
of course
none of this is real
but it all could be
this could be real I don't know
summaries touch my skin
can you imagine
and a year for the day that they finally
do
finding the children to achieve that but
do not worry I will practice the safest
of procedures
what whatever I decide to do with the
adults I will make sure to keep one
alive and Saints so that the surviving
children are delivered to the circle
safe and sound
to deliver me to where I choose to be
[Music]
live this simple life of a completely
brainless jellyfish
just munching on shrimps and avoiding
getting eaten
but you never appreciate how calming it
is to have no conscience until you have
one
I admire your cage
so I'm giving you the chance to walk
away
thank you
that way you influence both your life
and the chances of your child
um
okay ah
so was that a threat were you
threatening me
um
cause I am threatened
I'm very threatened no liver no
intestines hi most importantly
no pancreas what sorry sir need to have
more organs
what am I supposed to eat when there's
nothing to eat
guess I'm going to have to look
elsewhere
well
what is happening
oh here I am again so I don't have a
liver uh oh
[Music]
oh God
I am a shoot shoot
wow that is that's fun
why
[Music]
and
uh
uh but all right I'm a jellyfish now and
that explains why I have no organs
um do I need to play this game
uh-huh
right
[Music]
wow
I can't believe they're making me play
this again I can't believe it because I
was like in the last game I was like oh
man this was the most uh
incongruous like strange what hit it
hit it what are you doing
yeah this was like the strangest
seemingly out of context thing that
could possibly be here and yet here I am
again no what in the world
[Music]
okay
yay
I did it oh the door right that's more
important than the prize okay so we did
that
oh man all right
why
why am I here why am I a jellyfish
why any of this
what is happening why is everything so
chromatically aberrated
oh God I can jump
the squagoosh I guess
oh
what
oh wait oh I I thought I was loading
oh
oh hi
what you are not one of them hi
maybe you need to hide
what what do you mean
explain yourself oh
what
what do you mean okay now am I loading
into a different area
yes I am okay I am confused I have no
idea what's going on and I have no idea
why
Catch 10 criminals
[Music]
huh oh
I must be in the arboreal part okay
hi bucket how are you doing oh I got a
bucket I have a living bucket is that a
criminal
oh it is a criminal okay
I gotta get my prize you Criminal
come with me
you're gonna rot and sheriff toaster's
jail
there's more than you deserve
scum of the Earth
buckets I'm so confused
but I am accepting it because I've
learned the best thing to go about when
you have a game that just like utterly
confuses you it's just empty your mind
just accept what's happening enjoy it
while it's occurring and then just don't
think about it too much because if you
think about it too much then you're
gonna realize that none of this makes
any sense and you're lost in a void of a
facility with no bottom looking for a
child that I've never seen even I don't
even have a picture of them
boss room he's not bossy he's just the
boss
uh
oh interesting
at least you're having fun
hello what press me to start round one
round one
round one of what
it empty my mind
don't worry about it so much I don't
even have the blue key card so how can I
start round one
what's my prize
was that 10. yes
thank you
it's amazing how I get exactly what I
need exactly when I need it round one
start I don't care what it is I'm gonna
have fun hello
what are you
father jump on the lights and say oh I
should have read the instructions ah
jump jump
[Music]
uh
that kind of fun
[Music]
I did it I have a hat
for my drone follow the light Trail and
jump on the license they appear all
right round two
oh yeah
[Music]
those aren't the notes that just played
again not the No Such displayed
[Music]
I don't know what the punishment would
have been if I didn't do that right and
I don't know why I got whoa
how do you explain that one
and also what's up with that
and also why did I get a hat is there
some
[Music]
secure code uh lyxian please scan that
once again but blur it for everybody
else so that we know what it is risk
your phone it's okay it may blow up but
it's a worthy sacrifice
no I won't be buying you a new one
I'm sure it'll be fine just scan it it's
fine
k6 remains in an unstable mental state
attacking anyone or anything that
attempts to approach them and not
responding to any instructions delivered
through speakers despite being released
for solitary for much of the day they
choose to stay huddled in the corner of
their holding chamber choosing to pace
around the room while Whispering
themselves insensibly words that were
made out to include but are not limited
to gyvanium pancreas Beverly and uthman
context to usage of these terms remains
absent a request to upper management has
been submitted regarding usage of
unorthodox methods of sedation such as
the application of modified gyvanium
solution and potentially the
introduction of a companion we await
their response case is not ready for
presentation I don't think any of these
are and also
if there's one thing I know is more of
this weird chemical that created these
things and caused uncontrolled growth
that's gonna sedate it real good
real calm
um but I think well do I want to go to
spider land
[Music]
what happened to you is one of stinger
Flynn's tricks
he left for the progressive sector but
we have something more important to deal
with right now
see nabnab's room it's open now which
means he's inside
he's only hunt and it's too dangerous to
do anything in this state we have to
deal with him do we luckily I have a
solution but you won't like it that's it
to the medical sector and we'll talk
there I don't want to go to the medical
sector I don't want to go to the medical
sector why would I want to go to the
medical sector that sounds horrible
that's a big speaker
well I gotta press it
oh really I do I want to be deaf from
the audio discs that I find I'm sure I
do
oh boy I love these science reports case
13 as as has happened in the beginning
with most prior cases it finally started
showing signs of body and brain activity
which means actual testing will be
possible soon dormancy for two to three
weeks has been observed in all prior
cases when gyvanium and the genomes are
first mixed and placed into a body case
13 is an abnormality in this aspect
k-13's body has been only been in the
expected dormant state for a single day
and neuroactivity has already been
observed this is new a proposed theory
is this phenomenon being the direct
result of the modifications applied to
the gyvanium solution for being used
after the testing of case 12g which
would allow for maximum learning speed
case is not ready for presentation
uh election scan it's okay I know what
happened to your last
phone but it's fine
yeah look it's just not in the budget to
buy a new one just use the old one duct
tape it together and it'll be fine it'll
be fine
if I just got duck down here
it'll be fine fine good job okay well
it's all about learning here huh so it's
is it a kindergarten for children or is
this a kindergarten for the horrible
demons or are you stuffing the the
children into the horrible demons also
what happens if I go in here hi am I
gonna die
what
well that um
I guess I should have expected that
I have no idea where I'm going to be
reincarnated I hope it's not too far
back okay not too far back
[Music]
oh it's afterwards I think they knew
that people might want to go in there
for some reason can I put my hat on my
drone
hat wizard hat done where are you
there you are come hither
oh look at you
ain't you cute ah you're adorable okay
moving on I need to get to the medical
sector
which means that I gotta go into the
giant void of nothingness which was
certainly fun but at the same time hope
I never have to do that again and yet
here I go
I think it was this way we
hello
can you Reveal Your Secrets to me
ah hey what's up how's it going who's in
here why am I here
you know I thought we were gonna talk
when I got to the medical sector but
you're not talking very much kind of
leaving me in the lurch
do I want to go into this spooky room
I don't uh I checked with myself
mentally and I don't
man you know for for a proprietary
chemical I would think that this would
be a little more securely locked up
it seems to just kind of be out in the
open for everybody to see
oh what is that supposed to be green and
not yellow I thought I had a yellow fine
I'll go into the dark spooky room that I
don't want to go into
is this another trap because if it is I
will be mad and then do nothing about it
because I'm I'm largely impotent in this
scenario oh God
[Music]
wouldn't happen to have this cake it
wasn't long before workers started to
disappear
of course precautions and trading can
only get you so far so we had to think
of a more permanent solution NAB nolina
was that solution we had a theory that
mad now was as aggressive as he was due
to his loneliness
we never got to prove this Theory right
that's the collapse happen during the
surgery
that's where you come in carrying out
the final steps of said surgery givenium
related procedures are very delicate so
I'm going to need you to pay very close
attention to these instructions the hard
part is already done all you need to do
is mix the right concentrations and
inject her with it about six thighs
the machine with the droplet symbol is
where that's done when it's time the
screen will light up with the symbol of
the needed concentration for Simplicity
the concentrations have been represented
by colors mix and achieve the right
concentration then collect it in the
syringe and give it to National League
the machine with the colored pipes will
occasionally shift to the wrong colors
and when that happens use the given
tongs to revert them all to their normal
state of green the buttons on the walls
will also malfunction at times
when that happens hit any ones that are
lit with your drill the excess gervanium
that you can find in the room will
deplete when anything malfunctions or
when a concentration is needed to be
delivered the procedure stops if any of
the four deep leads completely
and what happens next is never good only
the best of us perform gervanian
procedures but we don't have much of a
choice
good luck the best of I thought you were
one of these jivanium creatures isn't
that what I
isn't that what I heard
oh that's what I heard uh okay I think I
got that I I don't uh
yeah
all right
here we go
I feel confident green oh well that's
easy that's green and green
and then do I take the server oh wait a
minute wait hold on
wait what
[Music]
okay okay
good I did that
um
uh uh uh What uh oh God okay
um and then where's my remote my remote
where's my drone drone
oh God no
oh my God how are you this terrible at
everything uh
you're not even giving me a color okay
okay and then this which is blue and
green
all right easy easy easy easy
oh so easy
hang on hang on hang on
[Music]
huh
all right I did it I did two oh those
are draining aren't they oh god no
a green
easy
[Music]
oh come on
okay I think the trick is you just gotta
do them in the order that makes sense
because
certain things can wait on other things
and that's cool I guess
oh god there there those go oh hold on
come on God damn you
go there
[Music]
all right and then red that's easy
I'm doing slightly better
is that red that's not red is that red
is that supposed to be red that didn't
seem like red
I really didn't okay apparently it was
red purple
oh God
what am I done how am I done did I do I
did it six times my ass oh what is this
what hi
bye
um
you're welcome
happy to help
um
I think
not 100 sure but I think I did a good
thing probably
I hope that wasn't too hard
anyway grab the audio disc and head back
to the Aquatic sector and play it on the
big speaker in the lung why for a spider
unit oh
are you trying to tell me
that this is some smooth jazz and I just
made a lady spider so that the angry
lonely spider dude can
make spider babies
is that what I'm supposed to understand
that I'm just playing privy to because I
thought this was a family-friendly
institution where you know
there's gonna be wholesome I
hesitate to say
that I don't exactly want to be privy to
a spider reunion
oh well whatever
I'm sure it won't be that bad
I'm sure it will be fine
that this massive speaker won't deafen
me
go for it
stay away from doors
[Music]
whoa
don't like that tongue
can't believe I'm saying this but God I
hope that's a tongue
aha
[Music]
at last he's no longer miserable
I'm surprised they both weren't
originally members of the mutants below
they'd certainly fit this is
what whoa
oh
uh what happened
why
huh
uh you're not gonna say anything more
about the giant noise that we just heard
and how
I think I think the spider got
mordored in some way and what was that
you were saying about mutants below
all right well that's oh no
I can't move
oh I can't move hi
I can't see it overstayed your level
uh if you could move over a little bit I
even made you an offer but guess what
accepting it is long overdue
I won't get rid of you or collect you
just yet
I was never one to abide by waste
an old friend who needs you a lot more
than I do
they too are on a path to achieve peace
of mind
I already have more than enough subjects
to move forward with my aspirations and
my ultimate mental refinements
you just take a little nap while I
transfer you to where you're meant to be
um
okay why
you know I might have taken your offer
of help whoa
oh
hello hey you
you're finally awake yes can't blame you
for taking a nap feels like we've been
in this car forever
so singer when are we arriving at this
place called Beach I believe you're lost
nice
one job and you messed that up somehow
I am struggling to locate
asked for your opinion
can you at least put some music on since
we're gonna be out here for a while
that's what I'm talking about
what do you think about this
for just one second so I can focus on
the road
what do you mean focus on the road with
bingo in circles for hours
never trust a jellyfish am I right
Aquila
oh my God
security sentence I will stop your whole
body on those stupid party hats in here
oh my God
I didn't think we were going that fast
but uh it was one of those exploding
cacti
uh
[Music]
oh I'm a jellyfish again okay what am I
supposed to shoot Zam can I go in here
nope what am I seeing at the end
and why can I jump so high
who are you
oh
well that was a different colored
tentacle than I thought it was
oh
I'm passing out or nope it's just the
brightness adjustments I'll go forward
then
[Music]
yeah I'm not gonna worry about what this
room was
definitely not gonna worry about that
yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
oh
more mini oh well uh
[Music]
nice
I don't know if this is supposed to be
like a security system or something
laughs
nice
[Music]
whoa oh my God
ah
[Music]
oh I mean I probably could have just
jumped across
well I don't need to do that yes I do
oh
thank you
I mean it's lovely that I have I'm
passing out now
I was just getting used to the idea of
being a
squalifush
jellyfish jelly jellyfish finally I'm
freaking out who what hi
and there isn't much of a talker uh-huh
it carries here that big green guy keeps
checking in on us I think he believes
we're some sort of dolls
we could use that to our advantage to
try and Escape he cannot know that we're
alive every time we move or change
something in the room let's make sure
that it's back to the way it was before
he checks in on us again this way we can
inch our way towards escaping all while
he doesn't suspect a thing oh in other
words from his point of view the room
must remain unchanged
close the lights change color so run
back to your chair when the lights
change
where to start though so you give it a
try oh yeah
what
oh
huh
I have no cubes to place
I
laughs I have no cubes to please
you were cool enough to enter oh jumbo
Josh's secret jumbo Josh Land Lounge
uh oh I don't remember what order they
were at all
oh I'm doomed sit down he's coming I'm
doomed
I'm doomed
I don't know what I'm doing
oh oh
hi
hi no the doors weren't left like that
originally oh
hi that's a problem okay
I understand now I think
I think so I need to remember what the
order of everything is the doors that
were open and closed all of the things
therefore so they stay the same
including those boxes so that the colors
can stay the same and apparently I do
have enough time to get the
and training I don't even know what that
means okay so it's gray green red okay
whoops okay so it was gray green right
gray green you red yellow gray green
okay so I'm gonna take this
actually I'm a wait
what am I doing here oh
so gray green red yellow easy easy easy
easy easy
there are you there
I have no cues to place I don't think
you're correct about that one
and made it give
now I have many cubes I hope they're not
just hanging off the back of my ass
because that would be embarrassing
okay so that's fine
oh
yeah
sit down
you're right about that you're right
about that you're so right about that
it's a good thing that I will never
behind me is he right behind me he's
right behind me I'm not alive
okay back in business
foreign
how do I oh I can only add
ones that are there interesting
well this doesn't really help me
well that was
that was not even any beneficial
uh
how is this helpful
the answer is that it's not uh maybe uh
no but if I um but if I if I would um
but I wouldn't be able to um
oh interesting ah it's like a it's a
it's an order of operation stacking
puzzle so I have to be somewhere to be
able to do that I have to have this here
or else I won't be able to get up there
oh never mind
uh well you know how it'd be just
experimenting
yep
okay so it's got to be this one right
there's got to be something to do here
which means that I can put that there
and that there and then jump over this
my is my dude here hey get in here dude
dude get in here
wow that was fast dude
well done dude
[Music]
that's what I'm
it's a little tricky
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
back in time
um um um uh uh
uh uh
uh
wait okay So eventually I gotta get up
and do those other blocks but I need
more blocks to be able to do this so I
gotta be able to do something in that
room there
what oh
okay close close
I think I'm getting it just give me a
second I'll get it don't you worry about
that
no the drone's supposed to be out of
sound what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean
all right
that was my bad
yeah of course it's so simple
got it nailed it I'm the best nope God
no no no yes yes yes
why what do you mean what do you what
what wait no the board the board
oh God the board
why would you do that
why would you be so stupid
how could you be so reckless and
irresponsible could have gotten us both
killed
all right fine I'll forgive you for this
one moment
okay so I need to put that there and
that there so I can go up here and over
here oh really
these really that spread
no it's not oh I was right there where
is it get over here
get in here
oh
come on get get in here
oh my are you kidding
you kidding okay so if if I get
caught up
okay there we go
you just go there all right it's fine
but I don't how do I get to the other
one that's what I don't know
how do I get over there it's gonna be
times oh yep
you just stay in there
you stay in there
stay in there
okay we're back at it
easy peasy
easy squeeze me
so you just go
straight there
I don't think I can
how would I be able to
doesn't make any sense
oh I can I can't ah
[Music]
perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect
open
thank you key card okay
just in case
you never know and training
oh
good great oh it's dark oh what
what
oh
hi oh oh my
God
oh my God
what the hell
all right okay well that's that's great
um
you're not gonna say anything you're
just
running away
walking away not really giving me much
of anything just
and not even going in your own room
really
okay
well we can talk later I guess the
priority is escape sure hey
I think that's something
still nothing no nothing are we friends
now I don't even know anymore where are
you going what
hey
what what hey
what what
okay
that was weird
hello
um
well that was fun and informative what
that what
what
also what was I doing before everything
went to
crap
am I supposed to go to the progressive
sector I don't know I'm gonna go the
progressive sector
that's the only thing I can think of
yellow
okay so I did get the yellow one so I
should be able to go in here
unless some giant octopus wants to stop
me I don't care if you call yourself a
jellyfish when you get to that size
you stop being this I guess there are
giant jellyfish and those are horrifying
why
egg
protect your loved ones they love you
back the same
okay here we go again another QR code
Lexi and you uh you you can choose to or
not choose to I'll leave that up to you
today marks the first day the case 13
was introduced to its Human Genome donor
and the results were not what was
expected in clear contrast to what
occurred during the Revelation day of
both cases six and seven which resulted
in complete meltdowns at both of the
cases case 13 assured the original
genome Domer that he was aware that it
of what it was in its typical calm
manner this is despite having described
identical events to what k-6 has
described you regarding their bodies
such as an unexplainable immense pain
that persists across their entire bodies
as well as sharing similar physical
attributes such as body growth and the
presence of many large veins we await
Management's decision regarding the risk
of presenting a case that is this
intelligent and unpredictable case to
clients why
if you encountered complete meltdowns in
six and seven would you even do this
again that's for the jellyfish jellyfish
is a weirdo
[Music]
hi hello
how are you
what are you doing here
hi oh
all right
you got me
you got me on that one yeah
you got me I'm
I'm impressed you you really got me okay
so I'm not gonna go near
that how to tame a giant Angry Bird
achieve High Ground jump and land on the
subject's back interact mid-air
okay that was just that easy huh it's
just that easy there's no problem
there's no problem at all oh my God
[Laughter]
oh my God okay
um
well I could never get around
I
to get around that anymore
I no longer wish to get around that
okay k700 k6 is holding chambered today
and the results were not what it was
predicted once they entered case 700
very clear instructions of taking
caution and avoiding any provocation
provocation of k6 slowly made their way
to the corner of the chamber the k6 was
huddled in as usual K7 unsure what to do
simply remains silent stared at k6 which
slowly looked up at them an awkward
silence persisted for a few seconds as
if k-6 was trying to figure out what it
was staring at which was followed by k6
then standing up okay six slowly walked
up to K7 and against all expectations
simply gave her a long hug before
reverting to huddling in the same Corner
once more k-7 standing in confusion was
ordered to leave the room shortly after
case is not ready for presentation they
never all
so does that mean that when I was
standing right there there was another
one staring at me is that what it was
no oh yep I see you peekaboo okay well
that was uh awful why do I need to do
that
so three eggs equals three pink minus
blue equals two blue equals two
therefore pink equals four and AG equals
one
okay one one two
five
three
great okay
four three
oh frick that's two God damn it can I
reset this
uh I know I
I thought I thought I saw
am I stupid what am I dumb one three
four
one two five three got it
what did I do
Mr Kebab man be yourself no matter the
cost unlike me
without his costume
what what do you mean what do you mean I
don't like Mr Kebab man I don't like Mr
Bob man I don't like I don't like these
doors I don't like the implications of
the many series of doors
oh great more doors
why
no good
a note
oh God Hands-On testing with case 13 has
started in deemed very promised in case
13 is even capable of fluent speech
primitive instincts and proneness to
unwarranted hostility that were
previously observed in cases seemed to
be completely absent from case 13 if
accidental stinging is to be disregarded
however aggressiveness can still be
presented when k-13 is provoked or when
any of its questions go unanswered
aggressiveness never involved excessive
violence or fatalities despite case 13
being completely aware of its impressive
physical strength current testing
involves introducing case 13 to basic
human etiquettes such as shaking hands
without stinging the following phase of
testing will involve informing k-13 with
its Mission at this rate case 13 should
be just as ready for the upcoming bring
a friend day as Case 12g Case is not
ready
for presentation of course it's not
why would it be
[Music]
what
the
proboscis noise equals button equals
firework firework
equals bird probuscus I don't know
noise equals button equals firework
firework into bird I think is what the
what we're going for
okay I don't know oh
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh that's not a bird
oh that's not a bird
[Music]
I what
all right well that one to um well
oh hello hi again
um
what do I do oh God what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
whoa whoa whoa whoa there was no need
okay I don't know what I need to do
aha button
oh no okay
[Music]
man that's terrifying
what did that do oh there we go
okay uh
[Music]
uh
oh God oh God
ah
oh
okay so I put the firework on the tongue
and that's all we need oh God
I don't have another one
[Music]
interesting to have Boss music
oh God no God firework
[Music]
there we go oh God no no no God
all right you
you wanna play
I'll play with you
uh obedient to mashed potatoes don't do
it don't do it
just get ready
it's gonna be time any minute now
any minute now
there it is oh wait what
oh no over there
[Music]
okay I'm getting out of the way
that's what I thought
okay
I'm ready hit me
did I do it okay yes
[Music]
what what
what
the hell how'd that happen I was moving
okay so I got two hits in
I'm trying very much to keep him just
doing the tongue slapping
because I feel like at least that
it's more predictable and can be
controlled oh come on
oh good
I thought it was gonna be like a three
hit Wombo Combo and that'd be it
apparently not I'm not banking on that
projectile
uh randomly getting me especially later
on so I'm gonna try to just keep this
this way
so that I can get nice predictable
outcomes
[Music]
that was three oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
well that was a bit dramatic
feel like you almost did that on all
right
feel like you almost did that uh on
purpose
I didn't know any better
oh too stupid to figure out my strategy
so that's on you
oh
what is that thing what's the Wombo
Combo down there
uh
okey-dokey then
take that and that perfect
isn't that the outfit that um
was wearing
band if that is maybe that is I don't
even know anymore okay good job me
thanks me
what
I shouldn't hang around
why would I be hanging around
I don't know
what the hell was that
you wanna try me again huh
well you want round two okay whatever
okay bye okay
um you want a hat you want two hats and
over your pancreas
hahaha
[Music]
what behave forget
behave forget
three stones with one Bird
Three Stones with one person all right
it's quickly losing its charm gray
Stones
three stones with Wonder three stones
with one Bird Three Stones with one bird
and over your pancreas
okay
um
three stones with one person this is
awfully terrifying you know
and over your pancreas
[Music]
hand over your pancreas I don't know how
close I'm supposed to be able to get
here
I
oh
what happened
[Music]
what
the frick was that and what did I just
do
ah interesting
I gotcha now what do I do
what does it do about this
what do I do about this
[Music]
oh no
uh oh boy okay all right all right air
superiority time yeah I gotcha
oh
hi
uh
interesting
um
ah
what
[Music]
okay
bird writing is a new one I'll give you
that hi welcome what drives you forward
so vigorously I don't know I refuse to
accept that it's your protective
appearance of instincts
oh I know
someone has given you false hope
promised you what you want when all
along they had one thing on their mind I
pancreases
at first I was confused by how
everything was going perfectly in your
favor
despite you never being here before
and then it hit me
someone has to have been guiding on you
and as with most things I was right you
did have help
your friend here has helped me
tremendously
thanks to him if I witnessed a very
Vital Information
what information you asked I didn't ask
anything well
my turn comes
I will simply prevent myself oh
ah oh wow
uh what
huh
oh blue light crosses first okay slow
down slow down
oh God this oh man oh frick I'm gonna
get nauseous here guys I'm not gonna lie
I'm oh man
oh well that's not good
[Music]
I'm comfort
uh
what a strange finale but I kind of love
it
it's really nauseating but wow
not too slow not too slow
come on
gotta save the baby birds I didn't think
that I would be on the bird's side but
God damn
what a way to finish this who built this
by the way like I know this is all all
of this is very not purpose-built uh who
built this exact way to get out of here
it only means to escape is to
ride two big fleshy bird creatures and
then get them in the exact right order
did I do it oh oh I did it wait you
missed the stairs I think you missed the
stairs
um
uh well I well you can run away but the
smell of your pancreas will always draw
me to you
really
oh
[Music]
look out pink bird
pink bird look out
oh a hug
what's up
oh
[Music]
stop it YouTube
oh
what
why did you why did you just jump
okay
I'm gonna go now I think I can't see
anything I'm gonna go now
um oh bird baby bird are you okay
find the kingdom find the sheriff do not
let the gesture find you what
all right I guess
I guess all right you're with me bud
it's okay
what
hey Bob
uh good job
hold on
[Music]
I like that
I like that a lot
I was utterly confused for the vast
majority of it but I I really enjoyed
that
it had moments that made me laugh
it had some decent jump scares that I
felt were well I had some undecent jump
scares and has some creative bits there
I like that I like that a lot that was
such a vast Improvement
from this
to the second one and the first one of
course I think this is the best of the
bunch so far I think that they're
getting better sometimes it was still a
bit slow and obviously it's still
rudimentary but I can forgive that I've
always been able to forgive that about
these types of games because they're
just made by a very small team of just
either a couple people
you know just like not that many people
you just got Gecko and Ferris just
that's it I think it's well done really
cool stuff let me know what you guys
thought down in the comments below you
can see guard in the band van one and
two and wherever on my channel and thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
looking forward to guarding the band
band three or four that'll be very fun
so thank you and as always I will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]